[Music]
aging is a subject matter that for no
good reason seems to be shrouded in all
kinds of mystery and the reality is that
there is nothing in our genes that tells
us to age or tells us to die so we
naturally have to ask then why do we
write and it appears that there are six
hallmarks of aging six body processes
that are responsible for how we age they
can work for us or they can work against
us and how we live is what determines
the outcome of those results so the
first key that this is kind of how we've
we've listed them myself and my
co-author Myatt Murphy who's fantastic
is stress stress adaptation so when we
think of stress we often think stresses
evil stresses the devil it's so bad but
in reality stress is designed to make us
stronger whether it's emotionally or
physically like we can be literal here
somebody has osteoporosis or osteopenia
right they have their bone density is
becoming compromised with old age okay
well why do we recommend working out in
particular with weights the idea is that
stress is an injury we're injuring the
muscles we're injuring the bones right
stress was we're going to fitness in
this particular case and it creates
these little micro fissures in the bone
will the body we jump to our second key
which is inflammation has an
inflammatory response sends in bone
cells and says all right whoa we got to
heal this we got to get all this back
together at the bone remodels and
becomes more dense so again stress when
properly managed be it emotional or
physical is designed to either make you
wiser smarter stronger more depth more
empathy right or your bones become more
dense your muscles become leaner and
stronger and when you look at all of the
amazing things that our body does to
adapt to stress you see that it's there
to make you better right the second
being inflammation so without
inflammation you couldn't cure the
common cold however
when inflammation becomes chronic just
like stress right you've got this little
army of white blood cells are like we've
got to go to war with somebody
well when the key of inflammation
becomes ongoing and chronic it starts to
attack healthy tissue this is when you
get into issues like rheumatoid
arthritis for example perfect example
another big one is metabolism we're
looking at a body process in particular
called a Tov G so a tava G is really
where our body goes in and calls dead
cells it's like the garbage trucks come
in they break down the old and they
rebuild the new when we're eating
constantly so food timing is very
important and not only that but how much
we eat is very important so when we
consume food we've got to break it down
right we oxidize the food which creates
oxidative stress so okay
the less food we eat within a reason
we're not trying to starve ourselves but
we also don't want to eat too much food
and we put this in a place of what I
call calorie restriction so calorie
surplus you're at a healthy weight and
you're eating more than you burn in a
day that's too much food we need to
restrict that and match calories in with
calories out so it's the simple law of
thermo-dynamics right and unless you
have weight to lose we don't want to get
into calorie deprivation because now
we're starving the body so unless we
have fat stores or stored energy that
process of a toffee GE where we call the
dead cells turns on healthy tissue and
go after a healthy bone healthy muscle
and so on so food timing of eating every
three to four hours breakfast lunch
snack dinner in particular and creating
a 12 to 16 hour window of fasting
fasting not to be confused with
starvation and it has become synonymous
with that concept right these 5:2 diets
and days of eating 500 calories that's
not what fasting is fasting is a period
of your day where you're not eating it
actually has nothing to do with how much
you're eating
that's thermodynamics and that's what
you just talked about right with calorie
restriction so that twelve to sixteen
hour period is really
optimizing your body's ability to a not
focus on oxidizing food and free itself
up energetically speaking to focus on
other things like boosting your immune
system for example calling those dead
cells through etaf adji and in addition
it's less oxidative stress because
you're not eating all day long and
you're not eating as much so just one
example on the third key another one
telomeres the length of our telomeres so
our telomeres are those little caps at
the end of our chromosomes and every
time our DNA replicates itself we shave
off just a little bit of those telomeres
well when the telomeres are gone our
chromosomes can fuse together you can
get genetic abnormalities and that can
build up over the years and caused a
host of health-related issues in
addition this is how we start to see
things like gray hair because our
pigment cells start to die telomeres
super super super important key and you
have your epigenetic so your epigenome
so people say all of this is genetic
this is all genetic what is the way your
genetics express themselves is fluid
it's not static it's dynamic and of
course it is affected by the way we live
but what's most responsible for that
expression is your epigenome so your
epigenome is kind of like that
overbearing parent right so if all of
our cells share the same genetic
information what's telling this cell to
become a bone cell or that cell to
become an immunity cell and so on well
that's your epigenome and what's choking
off certain parts of your DNA and
loosening up on others saying okay
express this component choke off that
component and we can make this work for
better or for worse and in fact studies
are showing us that our epigenome is
actually affecting what we're passing
off to our offspring so there was a
study on Holocaust survivors and it was
found that their offspring their
children have a better resistance or
more resilience to emotional stress
so again this can be a super wonderful
fantastic thing right just like all the
keys can really work for us and make us
the best version of ourselves for years
and years to come or conversely they can
predispose us to cancer what have you
and here's another perfect example of
what the epigenome can do and how we can
make it work for us when we say muscle
has memory it's true
it's your epigenome that's remembering
and marking your muscles so to speak so
that when you start training again your
body gets in shape more quickly so it's
easier to get back in shape than it is
to get in shape the first time moving on
to our macromolecules which is our cells
the health of our cells how our cells
are communicating with one another how
they're duplicating and so on but our
cells are literally our macromolecules
are made up of proteins fats
carbohydrates and nucleic acids
macro-nutrients protein fat carbs macro
molecules made up of the same things so
that should be a foreshadow that any
diet seeking to remove a macronutrient
is inherently horrible for you
[Music]